de l'expression de ces mesures
concernant le mali donc je souhaite
plutôt que les questions que nous
poserons ce soir ne s'oriente pas sur
ces sujets on aura amplement la
possibilité pas plus tard que la semaine
prochaine puisque je rappelle que la
semaine prochaine on a un débat 50-1
donc chaque groupe pourra s'exprimer
amplement sur les mesures qui ont été
annoncées donc c'est où ça me semble
assez coordonnés
bien mais seulement monsieur le ministre
nous sommes heureux de vous accueillir
une fois de plus pour évoquer une
situation internationale
particulièrement tranquille paisible et
sereine comme les événements le montre
au jour le jour
avec donc plus particulièrement la crise
ukrainienne sur lequel nous souhaitons
nous souhaitons vous entendre
certes depuis depuis hier
les russes semblent faire des débats
font des déclarations esquissant un
début de détente
quelques images nous parviennent avec
des chars que l'on embarque sur des sur
des voies ferrées encore faut-il savoir
où elles vont
et bien évidemment les forces russes à
la frontière ukrainienne sont
considérables on parle actuellement de
60 % de la capacité terrestre russe qui
seraient rassemblés à la frontière les
occidentaux dont la france se sont
engagés dans des manoeuvres de
réassurance des pays limitrophes
je vous redis au passage monsieur le
ministre mais vous n'êtes pas au premier
chef concernée quoique qu'on n'a guère
apprécié de découvrir dans la presse que
la france se préparaient à déployer en
roumanie un bataillon ce serait pas mal
d'en informer
le parlement en tous les cas c'est les
retours que j'ai pu avoir donc légère
inflexion russie hier les états unis
avaient prévu et prédit une invasion
imminente tout en ajoutant que le
président russe n'avait pas pris sa
décision et donc vous nous direz si nous
pouvons imaginer un apaisement de cette
crise compte tenu des renseignements que
vous avez vous bien est-ce qu'il s'agit
d'une énième péripétie qui en vérité ne
change pas grand chose au problème de
fond c'est à dire le risque d'un conflit
terrestre de grande ampleur sur le sol
européen
nous vous bien évidemment nous nous
attendons de votre part quelques
éclaircissements sur ce que vous
considérez être les objectifs réels de
la russie dans cette affaire est ce
qu'elle va se contenter de continuer à
entretenir la tension afin d'en récolter
les supposés bénéfices géopolitique une
chercheuse que nous entendions il ya
deux semaines nous disait que si le
président poutine avait voulu envahir
l'ukraine il l'aurait déjà fait sans le
proclamer urbi et orbi comme pour la
géorgie où la crimée c'est la vie d'une
chercheuse donc voilà je vous tends la
possibilité d'y répondre au cours de la
semaine passée le président de la
république c'est parti comment impliquer
dans des actions diplomatiques menés
pour résoudre la crise en s'entretenant
à plusieurs reprises avec le président
russe est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
ce qu'il est ressorti de ces entretiens
par ailleurs est-ce que la position du
chancelier allemand un temps critiqué
pour son supposé manque de forme fermeté
est ce que cette position du championnat
allemand vous l'apercevez comme
pleinement alignés avec la nôtre est ce
qu'on peut en attendre des résultats
certains et certains commentateurs avait
même suggéré que et le président de la
république et le chancelier allemand
fasse une démarche commune mais c'est
vrai que c'est à la france de présider
le conseil européen donc on peut aussi
comprendre la manière dont les choses se
sont organisés ces périodes de tension
internationale intense où l'on reste
juste en dessous du seuil de
déclenchement du pire
montre bien toute l'importance cher
monsieur le ministre vous attendiez la
question toute l'importance de disposer
d'un corps diplomatique bien formés
compétents expérimentés et dévoué en un
mot un corps diplomatique professionnels
notre collègue catherine dumas vous
interroger au début de cette année sur
l'impact que la réforme de la haute
fonction publique pouvait avoir sur le
corps diplomatique français avec la
disparition progressive des corps des
conseillers des affaires étrangères et
ministre plénipotentiaire à partir de
2023 nous avons tous été saisis lors de
nos déplacements des inquiétudes le mot
est faible les inquiétudes que soulèvent
cette réforme sur laquelle nos collègues
socialistes ont déjà adressé leur thé
l'opinion dans une tribune
particulièrement clair à laquelle nombre
d'entre nous s'associent
dans son esprit lors de votre dernière
audition vous nous aviez dit être
investis vous êtes investi
personnellement sur ce sujet nous en
donnons acte bien volontiers vous nous
indiquerait aujourd'hui si vous avez
obtenu des garanties indispensables et
ferme qui assureront toujours le
rayonnement de la france grâce à la
préservation de l'excellence de nos
diplomates voilà donc deux sujets je
pense alors peut-être que dans les
questionnaires à dos tout en évitant
comme je lé rappeler les questions
concernant barkan on les verra la
semaine prochaine mais voilà deux sujets
qui peuvent alimenter notre rencontre de
ce jour selon nos bonnes procédures je
vous laisse la parole monsieur le
ministre oui merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice messieurs
dessinateurs dont je peux aussi
m'exprimer sur le sel sans aucun
problème le seul point sur lequel je ne
m'exprime pas sur le contenu de ladite
conversation nous nous devons d'avoir eu
avec le président du sénat le premier
ministre
moi je vous propose monsieur lui compte
tenu du temps qui nous est imparti parce
que ce sont quand même des sujets qui
sont très lourds parce que si vous
parlez du sahel vous allez est intervenu
sur le sahel est donc un moment donc je
vois pas aller buter sur les annonces
que le président de la pluie qui l'on
sait faire moi je pense que le sahel on
peut laisser la semaine prochaine on a
tout un débat à la même heure à la même
heure la semaine prochaine donc gardons
barkan je pense qu'il y aura sûrement
des choses et les commentaires à dire
concentrons-nous sur l'ukraine qui est
quand même un très gros sujet et sur la
réforme du corps diplomatique il en est
un autre tout autant voilà monsieur le
mini je voulais ça parle monsieur le
président j'ai un peu d'émotion parce
que s'il n'y a pas d'aggravation
spectaculaire des crises que nous
traversons c'est ma dernière audition
auprès de votre commission
fin pour nom mais je le dis au terrou et
les bus j'ai dit au début pour le mettre
en forme
donc ça fait quand même dix ans donc
c'est bon c'est des moments particuliers
oui mais enfin bon c'est des moments où
il
est donc
moi ce que je vous propose je vais
essayer d'être de changer un petit peu
le mât problématique puisque on est
concentrés que sur un sujet donc pour
qu'on puisse avoir un un échange très
très ouvert sur
la question de la relation avec la
russie dans laquelle s'intègre la
question ukrainienne
devrait d'abord vous dire que depuis le
début de cette crise
nous sommes
nous appuyons sur trois principes
l'unité
et la solidarité
la fermeté et le dialogue
l'unité
entre les européens
et je crois que nous n'avons jamais eu
à ma connaissance autant de consultation
de concertation entre nous que dans
cette période qui a commencé au mois de
décembre
jusqu'à maintenant
et je dois dire aussi que sur l'ensemble
des problématiques de cette séquence
grave
il y a une réelle convergence entre tous
les européens
c'est du je crois aussi au fait que nous
avons parfaitement échanger entre nous
que les réunions c'est quasiment tous
les jours
j'ai réuni
président de l'
union européenne du pape cette période
dès le lundi dernier tous mes collègues
des affaires étrangères j'ai réuni
spécialement
à bucarest les
les affaires étrangères du bénin 9 c'est
à dire de la fripe europe centrale
orientale et europe baltes
nous parlons souvent la relation
franco-allemande et transparentes bref
unités mais unité aussi
au sein de l'alliance
et je crois que sur tous les sujets
président de la république ses
entretiens avec le président bailly
donne régulièrement s'y sont rendus déjà
quatre fois sur la question aux
ukrainiennes moi même je m'entretiens en
permanence avec mon collègue blinken je
me suis entretenu avec lui hier soir je
me suis entretenu avec lui avant-hier je
me suis entretenu avec lui vendredi
donc c'est aux manants et ils ne parlent
pas qu'avec moi mais on a une relation
très très forte et très suivi donc nous
nous parlons beaucoup et je crois qu'on
peut dire que il y a vraiment une
solidité qui fait partie du rapport de
force
l'union
fait partie du rapport de force la
convergence fait partie de rapport de
force
et puis aussi une relation de
solidarité
solidarité avec
notre partenaire ukrainien
solidarité de soutien solidarité aussi
financière puisque
une des constatations que l'on peut
faire c'est que la l'ukraine se trouve
au cid fragilité du côté financier c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
apportées lorsque le président de la
république s'est rendu à kiev après
s'est rendu à moscou un milliard deux
cents millions de soutiens financiers à
l'ukraine qui en a bien besoin l'union
européenne elle même apporté aussi un
soutien financier significatif
pour éviter que l'ukraine soit asphyxiée
par ses problèmes financiers en cette
période
unité solidarité que l'on n'a déployé
aussi lors des déplacements du président
de la république y compris d'ailleurs un
événement qui on ne vit pas c'est un peu
trop inaperçu parce qu'il y avait là
l'ampleur de
des effets médiatiques de la l'entretien
avec le président poutine y compris la
région de berlin
qui s'est tenue à la fin de cette
séquence avec le prêtre le chancelier et
le président polonais parce qu'il se
trouve que en cette période nous
président
l'union le conseil de l'union européenne
l'allemagne préside le g7 et la pologne
préside l'organisation pour la sécurité
et la coopération en europe
unité qui se maintient
fermeté
avec le principe de
base c'est que toute atteinte à la
souveraineté et à l'intégrité tout
atteint nouvelle la souveraineté et
intégrité de l'ukraine entraînerait pour
la russie des conséquences massive
fermeté aussi sur les principes
les principes ce sont les principes de
la charte de paris de 1990 c'est le
principe de l'acte
d'helsinki l'acte final d'helsinki de
1975 à dire les principes qui assurent
la sécurité la stabilité en europe et
qui repose sur un certain nombre de
d'éléments forts qui ce qu'ils veulent
qu'ils disent chaque état est souverain
chaque état est maître de ses choix
chaque état et demande de maître de son
destin chaque état peut choisir
sa ses propres alliances le principe
c'est aussi l'inviolabilité des
frontières le principe c'est le non
recours à la force pour régler des
différends
différentiel territoriaux
voilà ces principes là il sort était
aussi signé voté par d'ailleurs pour une
partie par l'urss
donc fermeté sur sur l'ensemble de c2c
de ses engagements
qu'il faut répéter et dont il ya des
choses qui ne se négocie pas
on ne négocie pas le fait que l'ukraine
face tel ou tel choix et le cren décide
enfin souhaite garder l'intégrité de ses
frontières
le laisse sur les sanctions
je parlais tout à l'heure d'unité des
européens et d'unité des alliés c'est
aussi le cas
les sanctions elles se veulent
dissuasive
je n'en ferai pas état pour des raisons
que vous comprendrez
c'est la nécessité de maintenir aussi
l'ambiguïté du dispositif a fermé la
dissuasion la dissuasion mais ces
sanctions ils sont
travaillés au sein de l'union européenne
est en relation avec les états unis on
croit en confiance et convergence pour
les mettre en oeuvre si d'aventuré il
fallait le faire
3 troisième troisième principe le
dialogue
qu'il nous faut
impérativement poursuivre pour
montrer notre disponibilité
à travailler avec la russie sur les
trois priorités que je vais évoquer
maintenant en sachant que ce dialogue
est difficile
qu'il est exigeant
qu'il est parfois qui peut être parfois
désagréable mais il faut avec
obstination
rester dans cette logique là je constate
que beaucoup de monde se parle
le président s'est rendu à moscou il a
de nouveau eu le président poutine au
téléphone pendant le week-end mais le
chancelier s'est rendu lui aussi à kiev
et à moscou lé
président biden a aussi ses
interlocuteurs et ses rendez-vous
téléphonique bref ryad on se parle ça
bouge pas beaucoup mais on se parle et
il faut absolument garder ce principe là
donc c'est les trois principes qui nous
anime
nous le pense le président de la
république mais aussi ses trois
principes sont assez largement partagé
par par les européens alors les trois
les trois sujets sur lesquels nous
sommes année trois priorités sur
lesquelles nous sommes amenés à agir et
et aussi à essayer de progresser
c'est d'abord d'enrayer l'escaladé
on sait que l'ampleur
ces deux mouvements militaires
april cc
à la fois les manoeuvres en bélarus
qui sont en cours
avec au passage d'ailleurs
petite
réflexion sur ce qui se passe en belarus
puisque il y a non seulement des
manoeuvres en cours avec des forces
russes et des forces de la russe mais
aussi
une réforme de la constitution
la bélarusse qui va avoir lieu dimanche
en huit donc dimanche prochain dimanche
en 8es
cette réforme de la constitution en
dehors des aspects de renforcement de
l'autoritarisme intérieur entraîne aussi
le fait que désormais la bélarusse n'est
plus neutre et que
partie du texte constitutionnel qui
interdisait le positionnement d'armes
nucléaires en bélarus a sauté et donc
cela fait partie des
dispositions nouvelles que sur lesquels
le présent dans le public a été amené à
échanger avec le président poutine donc
premier premiers éléments première
priorité
enrayer l' escalade au moment où il ya
ces manoeuvres qui sont toujours en
cours jusqu'au 20
enrayer l' escalade sur l'est avec les
grandes manoeuvres qui sont préparés
depuis longtemps
sur la frontière est de l'ukraine
enrayer l' escalade au sud et on sait
qu'il ya aussi en ce moment des
manoeuvres importantes navale beaucoup
de bâtiments ont rejoint la mer noire
pour ces manoeuvres et je rajoute parce
que c'est pas secondaire le fait qu' il
y à aussi l'exercice de la triade
nucléaire là maintenant c'est tout ça ce
sont des exercices
mais il se passe tous en même temps
et ya jamais eu autant de mobilisation
donc la première priorité c'est ça il
pourra assurer que pour assurer qu'il
n'y ait pas de guerre
et commencer à ce qui est des inflexions
alors j'ai bien j'ai bien noté comme
vous monsieur le président
que on a tous vu des inflexions
gelé répète lundi dans une forme de mise
en scène
le président poutine reçoit mon collègue
lavrov et à la sortie le miz lavrov dit
il ya encore de la place pour la
diplomatie
c'est le premier signe si saint denis
lundi soir
quelques heures après le ministre
choïgou défense fait un signe en disant
les manoeuvres vont bientôt s'arrêter
bien mardi hier
on nous annonce que
il ya un premier retrait de d'éléments
militaires sur le sud est sur eux sur le
sud je vois
bon et aujourd'hui on nous annonce la
même chose sur la crimée
c'est mieux que rien
et ce sont des ânes etc sud des
inflexions annoncé mais moi je suis un
peu comme saint thomas
y compris sur des inflexions annoncé il
faut que les inflexions soit vérifiée
donc on prend ça pour un signe
mais je ne suis pas de ceux qui pensent
que la voiture du mot il y a ces
inflexions là je les ai résumé
par rapport à la semaine dernière où les
jours précédents où on était devant un
risque imminent de guerre
aujourd'hui la paix est arrivé
uniquement par deux inflexions
il ya toujours autant de force et les
manoeuvres se poursuivent
mais il faut tout faire évidemment pour
éviter une confrontation
et donc si les inflexions sont vérifiées
tant mieux
on est dans une roue sera à ce moment là
dans une atmosphère moins attendu et on
pourra engager les discussions qui
s'imposent
j'ai parlé des trois principes là je
parle des trois priorités la désescalade
enrayer le processus
de deuxième deuxièmement
la question de l'ukraine et du dombass
ce que les trois priorités vous allez le
constater vous le savez elles sont elles
sont articulés les unes dans les autres
la question du don basse et de la
manière de le gérer il y a sur cette
affaire à la fois
des positions de fond et le format pour
gérer les crises les positions de fond
ce sont les accords de minsk
et le format pour gérer la crise c'est
le format normandie
je le redis parce qu'à un moment donné
au cours des dernières semaines
certains pouvaient s'interroger sur le
forme sur les accords de minsk
je rappelle 2015
2015 et certains s'interrogeaient sur le
format normandie ils ont les uns pour
dominer c'est pas bon et formats
normandie non plus les uns et les autres
d'ailleurs conclut parfois dans
l'opinion publique or certaines
déclarations français en disant qu'on me
des américains ils viennent et puis
finalement moscou ne voulait parler
qu'avec les américains et que tout cela
ait lieu aujourd'hui ça néanmoins c'est
au moins aujourd'hui depuis quelques
jours derrière nous
le déplacement du président à blick a
permis d'entendre et le président d'un
sénat ce qui est le président poutine
dire oui il ya les accords de minsk oui
il ya le format normandie et oui voilà
le la base et voit le format
et que cela a été aussi approuvé par le
président polonais ce qui n'est pas rien
le communiqué conjoint qui a été publié
après la rencontre chancelier président
mâcon président du hgd a marre que cela
ce qui veut dire que
l'espace est jouable à dans la
discussion
et il y a eu deux réunions des
conseillers diplomatiques des présidents
au cours des derniers jours
qu'ils n'ont pas beaucoup avancé parce
que c'est long et parce qu'on en pleine
crise mais ils ont décidé de continuer à
se revoir
et on connaît les paramètres jeu
peut-être on a ça dans les dents les
dans les questions mais il ya d'abord
des paramètres sécuritaires le cessez le
feu aux lignes de contact
il est aujourd'hui renouveler tant mieux
dire qu'il avait été engagée puis arrêté
et puis rompu il est renouvelé et il
tient
et puis il ya donc dans ce cessez le feu
et les échanges de prisonniers il y a le
transfert des armes lourdes de
l'ouverture de voies de passage toute
une série de choses qui doit pouvoir se
mettre en oeuvre et puis vous avez les
aspects politiques et qui intègre le
fait qu' il faut reconnaître le statut
d'autonomie du dombass dans l'ukraine et
là il ya besoin d'un projet de loi qui
pour l'instant
n'a boudy pas et puis il a besoin autour
de ce projet de loi d'une loi spéciale
pour
l'application de l'autonomie et puis
d'une loi sur le processus électoral
voilà c'est tout ça et là il suffit
maintenant de mettre en oeuvre de la
volonté politique existe t-elle
je trouvais que
le président 1 1 ce qui
était ouvert il a posé un acte important
qui était le retrait d'un texte de loi
qui lui contredisait les engagements de
minsk active qui avait été à
l'initiative de l'ukraine et qui
n'étaient pas acceptables dans ce cadre
là il a pris il a eu le courage de le
faire bon est ce que maintenant on va
pouvoir continuer c'est sur la table je
n'ai pas la réponse mais voilà la
deuxième priorité la question
ukrainienne voilà comment on peut la
régler
les graines et libre d'après de même
parallèlement de faire ses choix le
destin comme elle longtemps
est le 3 le troisième point c'est sans
doute d'ailleurs le poids le plus majeur
c'est
le nouvel ordre de garantie de stabilité
et de sécurité en europe
hélas
il y a eu que vous vous le savez je
remets tout ça en perspective
d'une part
des
documents qui ont été
envoyés par le président poutine et au
président américain est l'hôte en
décembre j'ai vu qu'elle date dans des
sens
sur la manière dont la russie voyait
la sécurité qui était en fait une
manière de revenir à la logique de blocs
qui était en fait une manière de revenir
à avant 1990 est d'accord ou d'accord
autant eu lieu
revenir à l'ordre ancien en quelque
sorte logique de bloc jeudi de
l'affluence et voilà comment elle dit
pouvoir assurer sa propre sécurité je
vous fais observer d'ailleurs que ces
deux les plats ne sont pas adressés aux
européens ce qui entraîne d'ailleurs à
ce moment là le fait qu' on dise mais on
ne dit plus
abrous l europe cela est d'ailleurs un
peu distillées par les autorités russes
mais là nous sommes en décembre
aujourd'hui ce discours n'a plus lieu
nous avons répondu
à poutine
sur la forme d'un document
du président américain d'une part et de
l'otan d'autre part
parce que c'était un luxe avaient été
adressées mais nous l'avons fait de
manière concertée ces derniers les
fondamentaux du courrier ont été
élaborés en pas rencontré de
participation des européens
de quoi de quoi s'agit-il pour nous fut
de chez nous je terminerai pas ces deux
là dessus avant d'ouvrir la discussion
du fait qu' il s'agit du fait que l'
architecture sur lesquels s'était bâti
l'organisation de la sécurité en europe
est caduque
elle traitait à ciel ouvert on n'en
parle plus
il ne fonctionne plus puisque les états
unis et la russie ne sont pas dans le
coup se sont retirés
le traité sur les forces nucléaires
intermédiaire de vous rappeler on était
ici après la crise des euromissiles et
qui permettait de maîtriser les
armements nucléaires de deux emmy et
missiles à courte et moyenne portée en
europe il est caduc puisque les états
unis l'ont dénoncé c'était l'époque de
de trump mais que finalement à la russie
de respecter pas vraiment
le l'accord sur les forces
conventionnelles en particulier de
transparence et d'information lui-même
est tombé
ce que l'on appelle le document de
vienne qui consiste à donner des
informations mutuelle sur l'état des
forces lorsqu'on fait des exercices ça
n'existe plus non plus il ya plus de
règles
et nous avons tous besoin de règles de
sécurité et donc nous sommes tout à fait
disposés mais on comme je suis en
réunion publique je le dis pour qu'on
nous entende aussi à l'extérieur nous
sommes tout à fait disposés à parler
dans les instances qu'il convient de
définir de tous ces sujets avec la
russie on comprend que la russie ait
besoin de garanties de sécurité et que
les européens aussi et donc tout cela
peut être discuté mis sur la table à la
fois sur comment est-ce qu'on remplace
le traité et fait ni dans la maîtrise
des missiles à courte et moyenne portée
comment est-ce qu'on
s'informent mutuellement des manoeuvres
militaires que nous sommes amenés à
faire y compris des forces
conventionnelles comment est-ce qu'on
peut s'informer mutuellement y compris
de l'êta militaire de l'ukraine
tout ça est sur la table
dans les réponses
parti mais des réponses qui ont été
apportées et on attend la réponse de
poutine sur ça
et il a déclaré au président de la
république que la réponse allait venir
pour l'instant on n'est pas
bons je crois que j'ai dit si j'arrête
un peu parce que je vais trop long
voilà comment je vois la situation là
maintenant pour pour l'essentiel et je
suis vraiment prêt à répondre à vos
questions autant que faire ce peu parce
que des choses que je ne sais pas
parfait alors peut-être on va papier on
va prendre les questions qui ont trait à
l'ukraine parce qu'il ya peut-être dans
la liste des questionnements des
collègues qui souhaitent interroger sur
le second point c'est à dire la réforme
du corps diplomatique mais si vous
voulez bien pour la clarté du débat
puisque en plus le débat est retransmis
c'était important de ne pas mélanger les
sujets donc olivier cadic donc à chaque
fois bien sur ce sujet là sinon je le
garde pour après il n'y a pas de
problème
c'est bien sûr l'ukraine
pour l'instant je voudrais qu'on pose ta
question porte sur la problématique du
cren
bon allez vas-y pose ta question
merci monsieur le président seul
ministre puisque comme vous l'avez
signalé c'est peut-être votre dernière
audition au sénat permettez moi de vous
exprimer au nom du groupe union
centriste tout notre respect et notre
considération pour le travail
exceptionnel que vous avez accompli
durant une décennie au service de la
france non seulement comme ministre de
la défense mais également commises des
affaires étrangères
face aux difficultés face aux
difficultés face aux menaces face à la
complexité vous avez toujours agi avec
intelligence volontarisme et bravoure
sur tous les fronts vous avez imprimer
votre parc et les progrès ont été
éloquents plus personnellement en tant
que sénateur des français de l'étranger
je salue votre action faveur de nos
compatriotes en particulier lorsque la
pandémie s'est abattue sur le monde
l'aide au retour des touristes bloqués
le secours occasionnels de solidarité
les aides aux écoles la vaccination de
nos compatriotes ont démontré que vous
aviez toujours pris la mesure de nos
attentes votre projet de loi
développement solidaire et lutte contre
les inégalités mondiales restera une
référence vous avez développé une
certaine idée de la solidarité française
merci enfin d'avoir est essentiellement
à l'écouté de chacun d'entre nous jean
vient la question qui est effectivement
une dégression par rapport à l'ukraine
pourtant signataire des accords de
dayton la russie prend désormais le
parti opposé elle a déposé un projet de
résolution au conseil de sécurité de
l'onu visant à supprimer le poste de
haut représentant le projet a échoué car
seule la chine la beauté avec la russie
monsieur dodik actuellement membres de
la présidence tripartite bosnienne a
fait défier défilé dimanche 9 janvier à
banias luca les forces de police bosno
serbes avec à leurs côtés les loups de
la nuit un groupe ii le russe
nationaliste et pro kremlin qui avait
pour l'occasion revêtu des uniformes
paramilitaires noir le défilé militaire
s'est tenue en présence de l'ambassadeur
de russie et de représentants de la
chine en réponse à ma question à
l'ambassadeur de la fédération de russie
en france pour savoir si la russie
soutenait le projet séparatiste de
monsieur dodik en bosnie celui ci a
revendiqué ces bonnes relations avec
monsieur dodik et marquer sa sympathie
pour contrer ce qu'ils qualifient de
réunification force est de la bosnie
herzégovine
ne pensez-vous pas que l'attitude de la
russie soit de nature à exacerber de
nouvelles tensions en bosnie comment la
france et l'union européenne observe
cette situation en bosnie merci c'était
vraiment une question connexe
alors est ce que joël guerriau souhaite
poser une question sur l'ukraine oui
président de leurs alourdir l'ukraine
merci monsieur le ministre en tout cas
de votre intervention je voudrais
simplement moi aussi on m'a associé à la
remarque vous a fait de mandature et
dans des conditions qui sont qu'un
particulièrement hasardeuse j'ose dire
que le monde dans lequel nous vivons est
un monde extrêmement
extrêmement dangereux et dieu sait que
la france en la matière est un médiateur
utile et nécessaire et que la diplomatie
a besoin d'être de d'acteurs permettant
d'éviter le pire monsieur mise
concernant l'ukraine moi ce qui
m'interroge je vous l'avais dit il y a
le comment les accords de mixte et puis
derrière le format normandie
pourquoi ça a échoué parce que
finalement si on est là c'est qu'il ya
un échec moi j'aimerais bien qu'on ait
de l'objectivité parce que
on voit et vous venez de le dire qu'il y
avait un projet de loi qui était dans
les tablettes du président dennis lee
qui correspond pas à cordes au mix lors
pourquoi on signe des accords sont les
respectent pas manifestement lag
l'ukraine ne les a pas respectées eu
égard au fait qu'il ya eu aucun débat
dans au parlement ukrainien pour les
mettre en oeuvre donc je pense qu'il
faut faire la part des choses je pense
qu'il faut essayer de regarder glee
creuser la responsabilité des uns et des
autres on a tendance à avoir un discours
plutôt
russophobe et je pense que c'est une
erreur je pense qu'il faut rester très
mais je n'ai pas le coût de la vie est
un bien évidemment dont l'entente dans
les médias je pense qu'il faut être
extrait seuil est de revenir à beaucoup
d'objectivité pour analyser les sites la
situation pourquoi nous en sommes
arrivés là la part de responsabilité de
chacun en la matière est resté dans une
seule forme d'objectivité sur les haies
prendre de la hauteur par rapport à ce
qui se passe je pense que les américains
auront une font beaucoup de pression
exagère parfois sur la forme ce qui me
ramène d'ailleurs à notre époque où il
ya eu cette malheureuse interventions en
irak et d'une guerre qu'on a peut-être
pu éviter parce qu'il y avait de la
désinformation parce que il y avait du
mensonge diplomatique
donc je n'arrive pas à trouver un et
voir clair dans cette situation entre
l'ukraine et la russie en tout cas j'ai
l'impression que les torts sont partagés
et qu'on peut pas prendre position pour
les uns pour les autres et que la force
d'un médiateur sets gagnants
d'objectivité
maintenant je vais prendre l'ensemble
des questions j'ai dit une trop longue
j'ai une trop longue lice alors on va
essayer d'avancer j'abonde sur cette
question j'aimerais bien savoir ce que
le président de la république a dit à
monsieur et l'ins qui quand il l'a vu
effectivement c'est un volet qu'on
évoque peu olivier cigolotti ukraine
l'ukraine monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre je m'associe bien
sûr aux propos de notre collègue en vous
remerciant pour la bienveillance que
vous avez eu vis-à-vis du du parlement
et notamment du sénat vous avez évoqué
les enjeux de sécurité monsieur le
ministre qui sont au coeur des
détentions
l'ukraine la russie les états unis et
l'europe et notamment dans votre
dernière intervention sur le traité des
armes à portée intermédiaire
ce traité a été dénoncé à la fois par
les états unis puis par la russie
notamment sur le fait qu' ils
empêchaient de posséder des armes dont
dans le même temps la chine se dotait
est-ce qu'il vous semble encore
aujourd'hui alors que les tensions sont
à leur apogée est-ce qu'il vous semble
encore possible de revenir sur ce sujet
de discuter à la fois avec les états
unis est à la fois avec la russie sur la
possibilité de remettre en place un
traité
vous semble-t-il encore possible
comme vous l'avait énoncé dans votre
propos liminaire de rediscuter sur
l'équilibré des forces et notamment des
forces conventionnelles et puis
également n'est-il pas trop tard pour
rediscuter de la transparence en matière
d'exercice militaire alors que les
tensions sont celles que vous avez
parfaitement décrite mer monsieur
merci olivier jacques le nay toujours
sur l'ukraine on est toujours sûr ils
traînent sur président monsieur le
ministre
si la russie venait à envahir l'ukraine
c'est toujours un risque quelles
sanctions la france en accord avec les
états européens appliquent rethel et
l'allemagne seraient est elle réellement
prête à renoncer au gazoduc north stream
2 lits à moi une cyberattaque massive
visait plusieurs sites gouvernementaux
ukrainien il y at il eu d'autres
éléments du de conflit hybride depuis en
ukraine qui n'a pas connu ses attaques
en ukraine et les états unis ont déplacé
leur ambassade de kiev à la frontière de
la pologne est ce que ça signifie qui
est que les russes projettent une
invasion et qui irait jusqu'à la
capitale ukrainienne
merci jacques cédric perrin sur les
mêmes sujets merci mais je voulais
parler de bretagne monsieur munich mais
on va commencer par l'ukraine non je
voulais que je voulais vous remercier
mais aussi pour
le travail et qui visait avons réalisé
un soin mr la défense et ensuite tout
misé 100 affaires étrangères et de
l'ecoute que vous nous avez toujours
prodigué
ses ministres j'ai une question un peu
plus plus de cash je suis évidemment
comme tout le monde à l'écouter
régulièrement de tout ce qui se dit de
tout ce qui s'écrit sur la question cet
après midi blinken disait encore
ne pas que les états unis n'avaient pas
de preuves suffisamment étayée ou
suffisamment affirmé d'un retrait russe
de l'ukraine ma question elle est
relativement simple quel jeu joue les
américains
dans cette affaire-là
alors qu'ils avançaient une attaque pour
aujourd'hui
il nous reste encore quelques heures
pour voir si ce sera le cas ou pas
c'est tellement grave que j'ai du mal de
perdre en faire quelque chose de
d'humoristique mais quel jeu rouge ou
t-il réellement quels sont leurs
objectifs
est ce qu'on a à faire même si on a tous
parfaitement conscience de la gravité de
la situation et de la position de
poutine dans cette danse et dans cette
affaire je rejoindrai un peu aussi les
propos de mon jeu et mon collègue joël
guerriau tout à l'heure sur les
responsabilités partagées des uns et des
autres sur l'analyse qu'il faudra en
faire est ce que
le j'allais dire le le mensonge de colin
powell de 2002 sur les armes de
destruction massives peuvent être mis en
rapport avec ce qui se passe en ce
moment même si on est évidemment dans
une proportion complètement différente
ma question c'est à quel jeu joue t-il
merci
merci cédric alors en visio maintenant
jean marc todeschini
le président monsieur le ministre van
vyve
tum évitera de trop longer les oies ont
su me viennent de vous faites pas de
souci
on assiste à un soi-disant une
désescalade et puis en même temps on a
dit cyber attaques massives contre nice
1-1 défense et 2 principalement que
l'ukrainienne on pense connaître
l'instigatrice le pays instigateurs de
ces attaques
john kirby il le porte parole du
pentagone il dit lui que la situation
n'a pas évolué poutine a annoncé qu'il
avait fait des propositions pour un
processus de négociations si je reprends
les propos qui vous sont prêtés dans la
presse il se dresse du vrai tout est
possible nous ne savons pas nous
espérons d'endroit où se glissent tchité
code assez bien mon jean yves le drian
qui a décidé beaucoup plus clair je
pense que les déclarations du sont
prêtés propose donc les questions
quelles sont ses propositions
quel prix selon poutine a fait
quelle est la position de la france par
rapport à ses propositions et qu'elles
sont déjà les mesures que la france a pu
prendre par rapport à cela ensuite tu es
les joues nous interrogeait sur les
additions vous faites sur les bains
havre où les avait abordés à des
manoeuvres qui sont faites manoeuvre
machine
bien sûr on dès lors eu si
vous avez dit que vous étiez comme
saint-thomas mais ce à juste titre
est-ce que vous pensez que le
désengagement
vers la vaillance d'ukraine va réussir
ou bien est ce tout simplement l heure
et des manoeuvres massives ont elles
permises d'importer non seulement des
troupes qui elles vont sortir et mais
des matériels militaires importants
en biélorussie des pays baltes que l'on
dit où ils sont très inquiet d'être
encerclés car si les forces russes
prennent pied vous avez évoqué lui même
le référendum qui était rogramme
biélorussie si des forces russes près le
pied dans le couloir de ce nouvel outil
c'est tout simplement pour eux la façon
de relier kaliningrad boys ont des bases
leur base et puis ça se couperaient
totalement les pays baltes qui
affaiblira en tout cas et la position de
l'otan soucieux des pays baltes ne
pourrait même pas recevoir de
rapidement de renforts ni par terre ni
par air ni par mr bref quelle analyse
faites-vous sur
cela n'est ce pas au talon d'achille
pour l'otan alors que le président
poutine lui dis tout simplement que
l'otan progrès ce n'est ce pas là pour
l'otan un recul important s'il des
forces russes devaient se stationner et
importer des missiles supplémentaires en
biélorussie merci merci merci jean marc
vittori on va essayer d'avancer un peu
ce qu'on a encore une liste importe
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je m'associe bien sûr aux
propos de mes collègues et je souligne
notamment votre capacité d'écouté votre
disponibilité pour l'avoir moi-même
éprouvé lorsque je rapportais le texte
développement solidaire lutte contre les
inégalités mondiales ma question
concerne l'ukraine les semaines passent
et la russie se distingue une fois
encore pour par sa capacité à dessiner
avec précision différents scénarios et à
donner le en quelque sorte le tempo le
rapport de force paraître
l'invariant des relations entre le si
don et vladimir poutine semblerait en
effet dans une partie d'échecs mortifère
que le kremlin parviennent à guider les
négociations de sorte à ce que quel que
soit le dénouement invasion de l'ukraine
où des escalades ils en sortent
vainqueur
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
dire selon vous le résultat visé
initialement par le président poutine et
la russie at-elle déjà gagné
merci
guillaume gontard
oui merci monsieur le président vous les
questions qui ont été posées
rejoignent celles que celle que je
souhaitais posez donc j'ai pas pas grand
chose à ajouter
non je voulais juste savoir si en lien
justement et sur ce qui se passe en
ukraine sur la nouvelle constitution
biélorusse qui prévoit l'abandon du
statut d'état non nucléaires et du coup
qui passe un petit peu inaperçu dans
cette crise actuelle et savoir du coup
si enfin voilà ce que vous en pensiez
savoir si c'était quelque chose à
prendre au sérieux et il me semble
merci sève andré gattolin
oui merci merci monsieur le ministre
félicite pour vous des années mais vous
envie de partir parce que je crois cette
stabilité que vous avez institué dans
dans nos relations étrangères et la
défense ne sont pas
à négliger dans la place que notre et
laurent que notre pays tient
lundi dernier le ministre des filets
ministres des finances du g7 ont
réaffirmé la possibilité d'être prêt
imposé dans un délai très court des
sanctions économiques et financières
je cite aux conséquences massive et
immédiate sur l'économie russe alors on
parle beaucoup de ces sanctions on a
déjà eu des sanctions après l'invasion
de la crimée c'est le caractère massif
et immédiat qui nous pose question parce
que si tel était le cas et qu'en
contrepartie la fédération de russie
décide de ne plus délivrer du gaz du
pétrole vers l'europe parce que les
conséquences sur l'économie européenne
en période encore hivernale ne serait
pas
peut-être au moins et six plus ou plus
important de voir déstabilisante pour
nos économies quand on voit aujourd'hui
la sensibilité de nos concitoyens dans
la situation parce que vides aux
questions de pouvoir d'achat et prix de
l'énergie sa première question puis le
deuxième point c'est une remarque sur
les déclarations récentes du premier
ministre japonais monsieur kumo kishida
que je trouve intéressante parce que
c'est la première fois que je vois sur
une situation ce qui apparaît être un
conflit entre guillemets régional russie
russie ukraine
de voir le japon prendre des positions
aussi forte avec des actes de solidarité
proposant pour l'ukraine certes on est
bien en dessous de ce que fait l'union
européenne mais des prêts à hauteur de
100 millions de dollars de données on te
les cas de deux de vendre une partie des
stocks de gaz gnl dont dispose le japon
et dont il a trés besoin donc j'ai
l'impression qu'un nouveau statut et une
nouvelle place en tous les cas dans
l'alignement de l'ordre international
entre du japon alors c'est vrai que j'ai
jamais eu de traité de paix signé entre
l'urss et du japon après la guerre mais
d'habitude le japon est beaucoup plus
prudent donc on a l'impression qu'il est
dans un ralliement alors est-ce que
céder à la question russe est-ce que
c'est plus généralement la situation
géopolitique globale par rapport à la
chine et la région qui joue là dessus je
vous remercie merci andré andré vallini
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je m'associe bien sûr à tous
mes collègues pour vous remercier de
votre disponibilité à l'égard du sénat
et je vous rappelle qu'il ya cinq ans
vous avez fait les mêmes à dieu devant
la commission des affaires étrangères et
de la défense donc l'avenir n'était
crédules par monsieur le ministre ma
question sera beaucoup plus courte que
celle de la plupart de mes très estimés
collègues et beaucoup moins profonde
bien sûr beaucoup plus anecdotique aux
yeux de certains et au risque de dire
itema très estimé collègue joëlle
garriaud-maylam est ce que vous ne
pensez pas monsieur le ministre que
tenir une assemblée parlementaire de
l'otan à kiev au mois de juin est une
provocation à l'égard de poutine on n'a
pas besoin de dot d'aggraver la tension
qui existe entre l'ouest et l'est je
considère pour ma part très humblement
que c'est une mauvaise idée
sommes nombreux à penser la même chose
mais vous ne direz votre sentiment
nicole durand temps merci andré
monsieur le président c'est sur la
diplomatie je voulais poser ma question
c'est pas sur le créneau ah bon alors je
elle reviendra tout à l'heure et enfin
toujours sur le cren michel gréaume
bon très bien alors voilà vous pouvez
répond sans de ces questions sur
l'ukraine et on viendra près aux autres
il ya déjà
assez bon
les points les points les plus
importants étaient ont été soulignés
d'abord peut-être
parce que plusieurs longs super en
particulier mais ce guerriau d'une
certaine manière
aussi
s'était défini aussi
la situation de la relation avec les
états unis
n'est pas
du tout la même que
l'airé faut que les références
auxquelles vous faites allusion
en particulier dans le dans l'affairé
irakienne
et je serais même tenté de dire même pas
du tout la même situation je viens de
ville il ya peu de temps
dans la manière de gérer la sortie
d'afghanistan
je le dis très très très honnêtement
les etats-unis nous font part de leurs
constatations
et je dois dire que sur l'analyse des
forces
sommes tous d'accord
de quoi ces faits comment c'est fait ou
sont-ils quels sont les déploiements qui
s'ajoute nous sommes tous d'accord
et donc c'était un scénario totalement
totalement différente de ce que j'ai pu
connaître pendant d'autres moments dans
d'autres crises
et il n'y a pas entre les les alliés
et entre les membres
de l'union européenne qui sont pas
automatiquement l'otan
on s'informe de
la plus grande clarté il ya aux cadets à
cordes analyse
je le redis ici parce que je les dis
déjà deux reprises publiquement dans des
médias
nous constatons que toutes les
conditions sont réunies pour une
opération d'intervention massive de la
part de forces russes sur l'ukraine
voilà nous constatons
mais est ce que le président poutine a
décidé de la faire non
en tout cas pas à cet instant et les
mesures d'inflexion que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure mais je crois que j'ai en même
temps mais
de dd des réserves sur ce que ça voulait
dire inflexion annoncé inflexion à
vérifier est ce que c'est une rotation
identifier une seule fois d'ailleurs par
le ministre de la défense hier ou est ce
que c'est un retrait
et ont été mises la défense - mais je
sais que connaît la différence entre une
rotation est en retrait
bon donc à vérifier mais sur le reste
on est on est vraiment dans leurs
constatations il n'y a pas de y'a pas
d'entourloupe
dans la clarté des échanges
ensuite la responsabilité du président
poutine
et
savoir s'il veut être
un
puits s'il veut que la russie soit une
puissance de déséquilibre
de créer des déséquilibres ça peut être
très longue durée
aussi veut que la russie soit actrice
d'un ordre de stabilité de sécurité en
europe
c'est ça son choix assez à ce moment
parce que les trois sujets que
j'évoquais comme d autres priorités que
je vous rappelle l'indispensable
des escalades la question ils craignent
haine et les grands enjeux de sécurité
sont articulés
je n'ai pas la réponse je le dis tout ce
qui évidemment m'ont interrogé sur sur
le sujet
et donc
cesser de référence l'a ensuite il y a
évidemment le
lusage publique d'information
qui dans une affrontements d'information
dans une guerre de l'information jouent
un rôle non négligeable
donc on dit qu'on sait ça et on le fait
savoir
et donc on dit qu'on sait que tel jour
telle date très bien on le fait savoir
aussi des gens des acteurs qui utilisent
des leurs mais ça fait partie des
demandes de la transparence interne
entre nous elle est totale je crois pas
me faire abuser sur le sujet tu crois
pas
ensuite sur
l'élaboration là je réponds de ce
chiffre les tipis et aussitôt déchaînés
nous avons là
oui ça fait partie de
je vous ai vu ça veut dire je vous ai vu
peut-être que j'ai tort au top je vous
ai au moins j'ai vu quelqu'un qui a
écrit ça ou qui a annoncé ça vous qui se
prépare à ça c'est mais mais mais le
président le président pluie n'a pas
pris de décision
je sais plus où le jour j'étais dans mon
raisonnement cieux sur eux
non c'était sur les le dialogue avait
avec la russie
je voulais deal à la démarche de poutine
puisque c'est au défi ne me demandez ce
qu'est ce qu'on a répondu à poutine la
peau de position de poutine c'est de
dire on revient situation de
de la fin de l'urss je caricature à
peine c'est à dire on revient avant 97
et on revient à la logique de blocs
c'est à dire que jamais l'ukraine nous
doit rentrer dans l'otan
il faut démilitarisé l'ukraine et puis
de toute façon
les pays qui sont dans mon entourage
rond une souveraineté limitée et
tout ça n'est pas admissible pour le
respect des fondamentaux qui gère
aujourd'hui je les dis en commençant la
sécurité en europe qui fait que chaque
pays a le droit de ses choix d'ailleurs
j'anticipe sur la belarusse mais la
bélarusse elle a fait le choix de dire
je ne suis plus neutre
c'est son choix
nous avons renvoyé à poutine des
propositions différentes nous attendons
le retour ces propositions et dans le
paquet des propositions différentes que
ma feuille à tour l'ensemble de ce que
je dis que j'ai indiqué très rapidement
tout à l'heure sur les bases d'un nouvel
équilibre
en europe nous comprenons que la russie
a besoin de garanties de sécurité
mais nous aussi
et donc pour ça il faut discuter dans
des instances appropriées il y à des
instances qui sont eux qui sont à même
de le faire il y à la poursuivre la
discussion entre la russie les
américains sur les armes nucléaires
ok il y à poursuivre la discussion avec
l'otan sur toute une série d'aspects que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
revoir peut-être l'accord entre le le
temps et la russie il y as au sein de
l'organisation de la sécurité et la
coopération en europe des choses à faire
avancer pour la transparence bref il y à
des
lieues des forums pour avoir ces
conversations
allons-y faisons le
pour l'asnav on n'a pas laissé élément
de réponse même s'ils sont annoncés
prochainement sans doute ne seront ils
pas satisfaisant pour nous mais si on
commence à se parler comme cela on va
pouvoir sortir d'une première priorité
qui est la désescalade
pour monsieur le nay moi je ne peux pas
leur dire des choses que je ne dirais
pas c'est le type de sanctions
mais le paquet des sanctions est assez
significatif il sera nous sommes prêts
c'est à la fois financiers économiques
techniques nous sommes prêts
c'est des sanctions d'une autre ampleur
que celles qui ont pu être mises en
oeuvre dans le passé
et c'est intègre beaucoup d'aspects tout
en précisant par ailleurs que dans les
discussions que nous avons
avec les américains et entre européens
comprend aussi les précautions de
résilience
pour éviter pour des sanctions qui nous
reviennent en boomerang
et pour anticiper sur les contre mesures
que pourrait prendre la russie mais il
faut que la russie sache que les
sanctions au sens aux prêtres et je dis
aussi à
ce n'est que dans le paquet de la
nécessité d'un nouvel ordre de sécurité
en europe il ya aussi la question cyber
qui n'existait pas dans les discussions
qui existait déjà de la fin du siècle
dernier il faut quand je dis que c'est
qu'à dieu qui a plus de règle là non
plus et donc est ce qu'on peut aussi
travailler sur des engagements de
sécurité dans ce domaine là c'est
l'intérêt de tout le monde y compris de
la russie où son petit
ensuite sur le plan sur la sur la
bélarussie plusieurs en ont parlé je
crois que j'ai dit les choses de manière
assez assez clair nous sommes très très
préoccupés de cette situation non pas du
choix de l'anneau de sortie de la
neutralité mais du fait que
il y à des manoeuvres en bélarus
et que on s'interroge sur le maintien
des forces russes en bélarus après les
malheurs
et du fait que par ailleurs la
possibilité de stationnement
des
d'armes nucléaires sur le territoire
bélarusse élevé
la suite
cette question a été abordée dans
l'entretien que le président à blick a
eu avec eux deux présents poutine
au présent le poutine lui a dit que
cet
essai hypothèses sont ne seront pas
mises en oeuvre
et donc le retrait après les manoeuvres
interviendra n'y aura pas de
stationnement ni de forces russes ni
d'élément nucléaire très bien là aussi
vérification
je fais observer une autre chose
concernant la russie que j'ai pas évoqué
tout à l'heure c'est le fait que la
douma vous l'avez noté monsieur le
président tient de voter un texte
reconnaissant l'indépendance du dombass
pas des deux des deux régions du donné
ce qu'elle est loin de
là aussi cette hausse avec ce processus
était en cours sous le président poutine
a indiqué au président macron que
c'était une initiative de du parti
communiste
russes et qu' il ne reprendrait pas
cette initiative à leur compte donc très
bien mais s'il aventure j'ai processus
l'année jusqu'à jusqu'à son terme à ce
moment là évidemment processus de
mesquer tombe il n'existe plus mais je
précise cela pour montrer qu'
il ya des
tentations des tentatives qui sont
faites alors que j'aurais possède
vraiment aussi à monsieur bériault sur
sur nes pourquoi ça n'avance pas
il y a eu
en décembre 2019
une réunion à paris
pour actualiser le processus de minsk
avec
la chancelière
madame merkel avec
le président donc comment
porochenko
non avec le président vienne inscrire
pardon qui remplaçait le président
prochainement
c'était une nouvelle donne le président
poutine était là et là on est il ya eu
des effets qui ont montré que le
processus était possible puisque dans
les mois qui ont suivi jusqu'en juillet
2020 on a eu un processus où je me suis
rendu aussi là bas après qu'ils
avançaient les prisonniers qui revenait
en ont retiré des armes de part et
d'autre face il y avait un processus il
s'est arrêté après il ya une dégradation
en réel je pense par
absence de volonté politique sans autres
mutuelles je ne le cache pas
et je pense que la visite du président
de la république à kiev a permis une
clarification de la part du président et
nasri
sur la fois la volonté d'aller dans la
ligne mais ce
processus de normandie etc alors comme
ordonné savez un petit peu tanguay c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure et sur
minsk est sûre normandie à un moment
donné ça attendra maintenant les choses
je croise autres sont bien claires
en quoi comment ben je ne vois pas
d'autres encore maintenant je ne vois
pas d'autre solution non certes mais
surtout pas beaucoup mais il soit mis
les principes sur la table je vois pas
d'autre solution d'autant plus que minsk
a été signé
votre signature vous avez signé donc en
fait
c'était pas c'est quand même pas vieux
c'est tout sinon vous êtes dans une
logique de renégociation globale selon
là mon avis personne sans personne s'en
sort
sur nos ressortissants
je voudrais préciser que
nous avons nous sommes extrêmement
vigilants n'a à peu près un millier de
ressortissants
essentiellement à kiev
et
parmi ce millier il ya une partie qui
est binational
nous sommes très très vigilants sur la
situation et de montceau on a dans le
conseil aux voyageurs
on encourage choc on n'encourage pas le
déplacement en ukraine en ce moment on
lit avec beaucoup de clarté
on a fermé les écoles
on indiqué à nos
aux familles de nos
diplomates y sont présents de
fonctionnaires qui sont présents qu'elle
pouvait rentrer on est en relation
permanente avec l'ensemble des français
sur place les une délégation du centre
de crise qui est arrivé hier sur place
pour organiser les choses et on peut
changer notre dispositif dans leur
quasiment si on voit pas la nécessité
mais pour l'instant les vols commerciaux
continuent à exister
nous n'avons pas pris la même posture
que nous les etats unis d'amérique qui
ont déplacé leur ambassade à lviv mais
nous ne l'essentiel de notre population
et à kiev et puis par ailleurs on a
communauté qui est beaucoup plus réduite
que la communauté américaine avait
oublié mais c'est une séduit mille
personnes plus beaucoup de devises de
visiteurs donc
on n'est pas dans la même appréhension
des choses mais on sera on est
évidemment très vigilant sur sur la
suite et sur la manière de réagir s'il
ya besoin rapidement
je
moi je prends pas position monsieur
vallini sur l'assemblée générale de
l'otan à kiev c'est une décision des
parlementaires je pose m'immiscer dans
le
neuf et on ne fera pas de réunion de nos
réunions se tiennent les notes à
bruxelles et le prochain sommet ce sera
à madrid au mois de mai au mois de juin
sur
les sanctions que ce gâteau la wiimote
j'ai dit à peu près ce que je te suis en
mesure de dire
les japonais y songer set quand même
donc ils sont
mais il dit aussi qu'il était prêt il a
dit qu'il était prêt à fournir une aide
financière d'urgence le premier ministre
chinois
c'est ce que nous avons dit dans le
cadre du g7
aussi entre les ministres des finances
du g7 n'ont l'on dit aussi et il y aura
une réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères du g7
qui va se tenir à munich
samedi donc comme vous savez il ya tous
les ans à munich un forum sur les
grandes questions géostratégiques et
cette année il va prendre une dimension
particulière d'environ deux réunions qui
vont se tenir à ce moment là et je
participerai pour ma part à ce g7 mais
il se la solidarité g7 et comme c'est
l'allemagne qui préside le g7 en ce
moment donc c'est ce qui fait
c'est ce qui donne cette inflexion je
crois que j'ai je répondu à tout le
monde il me semble
à oui sur ce que j'avais pas répondu sur
survole la bosnie
le fait que logic dodik pardon et
tentera de mener un combat néfastes et
donc il importe que nous puissions
retrouver l'esprit d'high tone
pour éviter les dérives que
ce qu'a dit qu évoquait là maintenant
c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons décidé de la république
d'organiser pendant la présence
française une rencontre spécifique
sur les balkans occidentaux tu va se
tenir au mois de mai ou centre du sujet
il viendra évidemment la bosnie pour
rappeler les principes rappelés les
accords et faire en sorte une vraie
solidarité européenne cet égard mais
c'est une préoccupation on tourne
évidemment
les puissances jouer tout leur rôle dans
cette zone y compris eux évidemment la
russie la chine les toqués ou si c'était
un condensé de
cristallisation sur sur place et il faut
que les européens soient la manoeuvre
ça se présente plutôt bien côté
monténégro côté
aujourd'hui le pénis côté
à skopje
macédoine d'une à nos côtés macédoine du
nord coté
l'albanie pense que ça devrait pouvoir
se poursuivre après avec la serbie c'est
les autres pays mais la bosnie
herzégovine la plus la plus éloignée
bien sûr donc il faut qu'on ait une
solidarité une présence identifié
beaucoup plus fort
or nous quittons l'ukraine avec des
questions alors il ya une question de
jean-pierre grand je crois que c'est
bruno sido qui veut qui va l'opposer
à la place de jean-pierre qui s'excuse
et nous quitter merci merci aux sept
présidents donc de la part de jean
pierre grand monsieur le ministre la
réforme du corps diplomatique préoccupe
grandement notre président et l'ensemble
de notre commission que l'on ne se
trompe pas de débat le président de la
république pouvait avant cette réforme
nommé ambassadeur la personne de son
choix plusieurs de nos ambassadeurs
thématique ne sont pas issus du corps
diplomatique qui s'en trouve de fait
enrichi l'année n'ont pas la question il
s'agit bien en revanche de ne pas diluer
les compétences de diplomate de métier
secrétaire des affaires étrangères
compris nous avons aujourd'hui un corps
diplomatique professionnels expérimentés
qui est aussi la précieuse mémoire du
quai d'orsay son excellence et reconnue
dans toutes les enceintes
internationales
souhaitaient l'enrichir par une plus
grande ouverture aux autres fonds aux
fonctionnaires et par une mobilité
accrue ne doit pas se faire au détriment
de la cohérence du corps diplomatique
dans son entier je crois dit monsieur
jean-pierre savoir que monsieur le
ministre que vous avez obtenu la
garantie de préservation du concours
d'orient et de l'intégration des
conseillers d'orient qui ne seront pas
contraints de devenir administrateur
d'état s'ils ne le souhaitent pas nous
aimerions que vous nous indiquez les
garanties obtenues et les points qui
restent fragiles merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je m'associe également à tous
mes collègues pour vous remercier de
votre implication sans faille pour la
diplomatie française ainsi que pour vos
interventions toujours claire précise et
sans ambiguïté au près notre commission
donc ma question rejoint celle de mon
collègue l'a précédemment donc les
crises internationales se multiplient
dans un monde imprévisible et complexe
le savoir-faire des diplomates est
indispensable notre pays a une
diplomatie très très ambitieuse donc
envisager une diplomatie sans diplomate
me paraît difficile donc quel effet aura
cette mesure sur la diplomatie française
je vous remercie
merci michel gréau
merci monsieur le président les rambos
de la diplomatie économique que sont
lancés depuis le 15 février dont le but
est en prob de valoriser l'attractivité
de la france et soutenir les entreprises
françaises à l'étranger
le premier web binaire commencera avec
le mexique demain notamment avec
l'ambassadeur jean pierre asvazadourian
excusez moi si j'ai écorché un petit peu
le nom pays qui est aujourd'hui
confronté à une vague de meurtres visant
des journalistes déjà 5 pour 2022
les journalistes sont la cible des
cartels ou des gouvernements locaux
corrompus liés au crime organisé
apparemment avez vous des informations à
ce sujet de plus plus de 550 entreprises
françaises
sont présentes au mexique
38 des 40 entreprises du cac 40 ont une
présence au mexique dont certains depuis
de nombreuses années les outils et pme
s'y implantent également maintenant
les entreprises françaises 1 cave et six
au mexique notamment d'aller au nautic
l'automobile la santé l'énergie
l'agroalimentaire
télécommunications
certaines entreprises fermant leurs
usines en france pour s'implanter à
l'étranger ont été confrontés aux
licenciements et pour certaines ont une
épée damoclès sur leur tête
notamment je parle de safran danone
valeo et d'autres comme teleperformance
est poursuivie devant l' ocde concernant
des conditions de travail dangereux
allez vous en profiter pour aborder la
sécurité des ressortissants des
ressortissants français qui sont la
protection des emplois en france et
éviter les délocalisations des
entreprises ainsi que la sauvegarde du
savoir faire français
merci
enfin joëlle garriaud-maylam
ministre moi aussi je m'associe à tous
les compliments qui vous ont été faits
j'ajouterai peut-être aussi que parfois
très souvent lorsque je me rends à
l'étranger on me parle de vous et je
dois de vous dire qu'en dehors de vos
qualités professionnelles se sont aussi
vos capi qualités humaines et
personnelles qui sont très appréciés
donc je tenais à vous lui dire voilà ma
question ne portera pas sur l'ukraine
parce que je dois dire que depuis des
mois j'ai l'impression de ne parlait
quasiment que de l'ukraine peut-être
juste un tout petit mot pour répondre à
la question de mon collègue andré
vallini qui n'était peut-être pas là
pour nous avions déjà abordé cette
question pour moi évidemment nous
suivons la situation quasiment au jour
le jour avec l'ukraine et il n'est pas
dit que cette réunion de l'assemblée
parlementaire aura lieu cela dépendra
bien sûr des circonstances mais je
trouve que pour le principe nous ne
devons pas l'occasion de le dire céder
aux intimidations et aux chantages de la
russie ce n'est pas la première fois que
la russie fait un tel chantage rien ne
nous empêche de faire une réunion en
ukraine qui est un pays associés à
l'otan actuellement et je rappellerai ce
que j'avais déjà fait un exemple au
svalbard où nous devions avoir une
réunion très importante sur l'arctique
et où la russie avait fait des pressions
considérables sur la norvège pour que
cette réunion soit annulée nous avons
tenu bon et heureusement parce que
c'était effectivement extrêmement
important diène mais encore une fois la
situation sera évaluée
et plus tard alors ma question porte sur
une autre région du monde donc et sur
elle porte sur la birmanie parce que
monsieur le ministre j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui plus
personne ne s'intéresse à la birmanie ce
pays dans une situation absolument
épouvantable il n'ya il y a un problème
d'acheminement des médicaments des
vaccins l' oms estime que 35 mille
personnes sont mortes faute
d'acheminement de ces vaccins il
faudrait très probablement un couloir
humide humanitaires ce serait évidemment
difficile de l'obtenir de la présidence
russe mais je pense que ce serait
magnifique la france s'engage sur ce
sujet à l'onu je sais que vous arrivez à
la fin de votre mandat monsieur le
ministre mais je pense vraiment que ce
serait un très beau sujet pour vous
donner un exemple 20 février s'ouvre une
audition sur le génocide à la cour
internationale de justice de la haye ce
n'est même pas un représentant du nuc le
gouvernement légitime légitimé par les
urnes qui s'exprimera mais un
représentant de la junte alors je sais
que là nous ne pouvons pas grand chose
c'est une décision sans doute
bureaucratique de la cj mais je vous en
prie monsieur le ministre si vous
pouviez aider ce pays qui nous regardent
avec tellement d'attentes tellement
d'espoir parce que nous sommes le pays
des droits de l'homme et nous devons
absolument les cds c'est vraiment une
question humanitaire cette question
d'acheminement des médicaments de la
protection des ong est vraiment
fondamental et c'est important merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le ministre parole pour
répondre à ces questions
par les deux là
de la diplomatie du corps diplomatique
je vais répondre aux 2 questions
géographique sur la
madame grès home sur le mexique
je dois dire que c'est un de mes sujets
favoris donc vous tombez bien
on a on a créé un conseil franco
mexicain conseil stratégique franco
mexicain qui se réunit tous les ans une
fois à mexico une fois à paris qui se
réunissent et le seul en présence des
chefs de l'état et padilla pas
d'aujourd'hui de de configuration de ce
type au niveau de la relation entre la
france et d'autres pays et moi j'ai pour
ma part participé à je sais 5,6 conseil
stratégique de ce type y compris quand
j'étais minot défense
je me suis rendu au mexique
va des pins décembre au 21 décembre
et je rencontre à chaque fois le
président le président de la république
longuement et nous avons une relation de
grande confiance
y compris de grande efficacité
économique que vous avez déjà évoqué il
ya beaucoup dans le quizz françaises
présentes au mexique
mexique a subi une pandémie assez assez
raide
et qui est soumis aussi moule à v
rappeler à
gang de
trafiquants qui dans le nord du pays en
particulier
sèment
la terreur
me rendre aussi à monterrey la de mode
décembre pour discuter de tout ça avec
le gouverneur
nous avons une relation d'une grande
confiance
marcelo ebrard le chancelier qui de la
fois numéro deux et demi les affaires
étrangères et était à paris avant-hier
donc de
travailler avec lui il est venu à brest
pour le sommeil des océans bref on a une
relation très forte y compris aux
nations unies avec ce pays ce qui nous
permet de faire avancer un certain
nombre d'eux
d'objectifs à la fois culturel et
économique humanitaire vraiment une
relation extrêmement étroites et est
significative je voulais je voulais vous
le dire par reprendre tous les points
que vous avez évoquées mais vous dire
qu'on est on est vraiment dans une très
bonne
très bonne position avec ce pays sur la
birmanie madame guillaume allanou non on
continue vraiment à travailler sur ces
enjeux
la situation reste extrêmement difficile
à la fois ce plan humanitaire ce plan
sécuritaire et le fait que les les
désactiver personnage essentiel soit
soit en toujours emprisonnée aung san
suu kyi en particulier et il y aura une
réunion
à bruxelles lundi sur la question sur la
question du german avec des sanctions
oui et on a déjà pris des mesures en ce
qui nous concerne parce que nous avons
supprimé tout soutien aux programmes
gouvernementaux
nous poursuivons notre soutien la
société civile et nous sommes
en train d'essayer de convaincre
l'asian
de jouer un rôle pour peser contre la
junte au pouvoir
ça avance et un petit peu à un moment
donné je me suis rendu à jakarta
rencontré sur ce sujet en particulier le
secrétaire général de l'asian et nous
allons poursuivre cela la semaine
prochaine aussi parce que dans le cadre
de sommets sur l'inde au pacifique du
forum ce lundi pacifique que nous
organisons donc de la présidence
française qui a lieu mardi
j'aurai l'occasion d'avoir une réunion
de travail avec l'asian qui sera
présente là seront entre autres sur la
question birmane dont il ya deux rendez
vous lundi et mardi sur la question
birmane au niveau européen parce que ça
ce sont des sujets qu'il faut aborder en
européen
sur la question
du corps diplomatique
je veux dire les choses très très
clairement il y a une volonté du
président de la république de faire en
sorte que la haute fonction publique
soient davantage ouverte soit davantage
mobile qui une diversité de formations
qui est le renforcement de la parité et
qu'il y ait une évolution des carrières
qui soit beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
souple est beaucoup plus partagée bien
et puis il y à la réalité de des métiers
et en particulier la réalité du corps
diplomatique
j'ai je crois obtenu 4 garantit majeur
vous venez de me parler mais je voudrais
vous les rappeler
d'abord le concours d'orient sera
maintenu et sera une voie d'accès direct
est spécifique au quai d'orsay et c'est
le ministère des affaires étrangères qui
en maîtrisera les modalités
d'organisation
est ce qui fait qu il y aura une filière
professionnelle clairement identifiés
dans l'ensemble du corps des
administrateurs qui sera la filière
diplomatique considéré comme un métier
deuxièmement deuxième garantie dans pour
vous dire que tout ça était simple mais
on est là deuxièmement
l'accès des secrétaires des affaires
étrangères savais le rôle qu'ils jouent
et comment ils sont essentiels pour bon
fonctionnement du quai au corps des
administrateurs sera plus favorisés
troisièmement
j'ai obtenu la garantie que le les
conseillers des affaires étrangères et
les ministres plénipotentiaires actuelle
qu'ils feront le choix de ne pas devenir
des administrateurs de l'état ne seront
pas pénalisés et enfin j'ai obtenu la
garantie que les agents qui ont fait le
choix de la diplomatie quel que soit
leur statut ou leur concours on rompt le
pouls la possibilité d'accomplir toute
une carrière au quai d'orsay donc tout
en respectant
l'intégration des plaintes principe
voulue par le président de la république
on a pu faire comprendre la spécificité
du métier de diplomate et la nécessité
d'avoir
s'éteint
c'est la diplomatie c'est un métier mais
c'est aussi une vocation c'est
c'est un comportement c'est un
engagement et donc il faut que ce soit
reconnu comme tel et je crois que je
vous dois dire pour conclure que
moi je voudrais rendre hommage à tous
les diplomates que j'ai connu au cours
de cette période dans des moments
extrêmement difficiles
la crise afghane on a eu l'occasion d'en
parler ici mais
vous avez pu aussi en parler avec les
intéressés c'était une épreuve un combat
une
sang froid
très très impressionnant mais le retour
des français pas des français
d'étrangers de ceux qui étaient en
vacances souvent l'étranger pendant le
début de la crise la copine de trois
trônes âge celui qu'on est dans une
croissance de 110 mille personnes que
nous avons ramené 370000 de tous les
pays du monde dans une épreuve terrible
c'était aussi en fait de diplomates
comme c'est le fait des diplomates que
je signalais tout à l'heure aux
questions d'actualité au sénat qui sont
aujourd'hui en train d'essayer de sortir
de la crise iranienne après des
négociations qui durent depuis dix mois
et qui font que ces diplomates n'a sont
en permanence à vienne pour essayer de
faire avancer le bon c'est sans arrêt
des hommages de ce type que je suis
amené à rendre mais je suis très heureux
que vous même vous les rosiers à cet
instant
très bien monsieur le ministre nous
arrivons à la conclusion et à la fin de
cette
audition qui peut être est effectivement
la dernière et
entend dans le bouquet de dommages qui
vous a été adressé par l'ensemble des
représentants des groupes jeu le feu j
ai ceci bien évidemment le mien au nom
de la commission toute entière on peut
dire pour les plus anciens qui vous ont
connu au ministère de la défense et puis
bien sûr ce ce quinquennat aux affaires
étrangères vous aura été le ministe des
temps troublés car lorsque l'on fait
la liste des crises que vous avez vécu
elle est impressionnante et sanaa ça ne
fait à nos yeux que renforcer les
qualités qui ont été les vôtres que ce
soit dans cette lutte contre le contre
le terrorisme et différents pays que le
cul que tout le monde a en tête la
présence la présidence de monsieur trump
qui nécessitait quand même d'avoir les
nerfs solides
faut faire face à nombre de déclarations
et d'initiatives américaine la pandémie
est jeune ou vous rendre ici hommage
je le fais au nom du sénateur français
et étrangers pour la manière dont vous
avez vous eu votre administration su
rapatrier ses 360 milles française qui
n'était pas une mince affaire avec la
cellule de crise et tous les services
qui se sont se sont joints je pense que
tous les ressortissants qui ont
bénéficié du soutien du ministère se
souvienne de vous ils se souviennent de
votre administration dans une période où
il était vraiment en grande détresse
difficulté aussi croissante du dialogue
avec la russie nous venons d'en de nous
en expliquer nous venons vivre bien et
évidemment c'est à la fois de votre part
la plus grande attention la volonté de
faire en sorte que la france soit
présente et l'initiative du président de
la république elle a été ce qu'elle est
et nous avons tous souhaité qu'elles
puissent aboutir et elle montre que
l'europe et singulièrement la france qui
exerce cette présidence française soit
évidemment
un acteur de
2,7 désescalade du chemin de la discrète
comme le président l'a évoquée vous avez
aussi traversé toute cette période
d'affirmations décomplexée de la
puissance chinoise a là aussi en se
souvient partout dans le monde de toutes
les initiatives qui sont prises et la
france là encore et l'europe bien sûr
puisque je veux venir personne n'ignore
que votre compétence c'était aussi au
premier chef ministre de l'europe vous
avez fait en sorte que nous puissions
d'une part bien comprendre ce qui se
passait et essayer d'y résister c'est
pas toujours facile mais en tous les cas
ça a été vraiment un élément important
l'implosion du gie cypihot et qui est
quand même là aussi alors que vous même
aviez pris une part
essentielle avec d'autres bien sûr mais
enfin
il ya eu une clé supplémentaire
les démêlés que nous avons eues avec la
turquie
vous avez trois tomes de mémoire en fait
à rédiger vous vous y mettre si jamais
votre décision était de de quitter
l'activité publique je pense que vous
auriez beaucoup de choses à nous dire
notamment sur ce sujet le réarmement le
réarmement global d'une manière générale
aussi vous l'avez vécu commises et la
défense et comme mise affaires
étrangères tout ceci a été très utile
dans la mesure où c'est un choix du
président de la république et c'était
beau de volonté de voir si c'est une
période de stabilité ministériel je
pense que dans ces moments-là il était
important que nous ayons au quai d'orsay
le même ministre entouré de deux de deux
usines de ministre délégué aux deux
secrétaires d'état nous avons regretté
c'est vrai absence de ministre de la
coopération parce qu'on voit que le
dialogue avec l'afrique et daniel
compliqué qui nécessite des présence
physique et pour vous laisse les comme
pour nous les journées n'ont que 24
heures dans tous les cas vous avez
véritablement assurée par cette
instabilité ministérielle une image très
cohérente de la politique étrangère
française
et puis ce que j'aurais juste souligner
en conclusion c'est votre votre
attention permanente au dialogue avec le
parlement et singulièrement ici nous
avons même soupçonné d'être sénateur en
puissance tellement vous êtes vous vous
êtes retrouvé bien ici dans cette salle
à nos contacts des uns et des autres
j'ai pour ma part l'occasion à moult
reprises de partager avec vous des
missions à l'étranger des rendez vous en
tête à tête et je me souviens mois du
ministre de la défense qui expliquait
quasiment semaine par semaine
l'évolution de l'opération serval les
plus anciens s'en souviennent quasiment
et surtout le sentiment de confiance
vous avez témoignée au parlement puisque
là on était au coeur de l'action on
était quasiment on avait les cartes des
chefs d'états majors ou presque et
je pense que la confiance ne vous a
jamais été
comptés et
ce qui est une bonne chose parce que
c'est un lien dont on a absolument
besoin on évoquait tout à l'heure avec
le premier ministre la nécessité qu'il
va y avoir d'associer encore le
parlement dans les choix essentiels qui
vont être faits vis-à-vis de barkan et
de
deux nouvelles de la nouvelle
architecture que la france va sans doute
mettre en place selon les et les
explications et les décisions que l'on
fera par le président de la république
je crois que c'est une marque qui vous
est très très personnelle pas obligé de
donner ce qualificatif à tous vos
collègues du gouvernement mais en tous
les cas c'est un véritable souvenirs et
une appréciation très forte de ma part
personnelle et de la part de la
commission et donc pour tout cela on
veut vous dire un immense merci on aura
peut-être même le temps j'espère
d'organiser si jamais tel était le sort
que vous vous donnez là l'occasion de
fêter de fêter ça de manière conviviale
on sort du coc vide
vous avez eu la gentillesse et un jour
d'été de nous réunir on s'en souvient et
je pense que ce sera bien que le moment
venu les sons les échéances et les
étapes passées mais on voudrait pas vous
quitter sans qu'un hommage vous soit
publiquement adressé au nom de la
commission parce que
je pense que les mots qui vous ont été
rasées sont véritablement sincère et je
ne veux pas oublier d'associer
d'associer à cet hommage votre équipe
rapprochée nicolas roche votre directeur
de cabinet qui a toujours été très
attentif aussi la qualité de ce dialogue
baptiste prud'homme qui se cache
derrière le kakémono toujours avec sa
discrétion mais son efficacité
légendaire est lui aussi une très grande
potentialité des coûte à toutes les
heures du jour et de la nuit notamment
au moment des crises je veux lui dire
ici mais je sais un immense hommage et
un remerciement on pourrait y associer
samir melki que je vois ici et puis les
autres je ne vais pas tous les citer
parce qu'après c'est une équipe que vous
avez animé et vous avez su du reste par
la stabilité de vos collaborateurs aussi
c'est pas c'est aussi une marque de
grande qualité ministériel vous avez su
faire en sorte d'avoir une équipe qui
est aux recettes dont vous pouvez être
fiers et qui
danse dans des matières qui réunissent
quand même un vrai consensus que soient
vos précédentes responsabilités
ministérielles la défense ou les
affaires étrangères on a fait en sorte
de vous aider on ne vous a jamais manqué
dans les moments importants
il compris quand on posait les questions
ce qui est normal et compris dans les
moments budgétaire on s'est inquiété
avec vous de la compression des eaux tp
la vente des biens immobiliers falla
liste est longue des petits coups de
tisons que l'on donne au gouvernement
parce que c'est notre rôle et on est
dans nos fonctions en tous les cas je
veux vous dire un immense merci
l'expression de notre reconnaissance
c'est une belle période vécue et comme
l'a dit
le sénateur andré vallini un peu taquin
nous avions entendu les mêmes c'est à
dieu il ya cinq ans donc ne jetons pas
sur l'avenir un voile qui peut encore
peut-être vous laisser d'autres
opportunités en tous les cas ce sera à
vous bien évidemment de de choisir entre
la bretagne qui vous attendent depuis
longtemps et puis ces affaires
étrangères ou moi j'ai pu constater le
nombre d'amis et de réseau que vous
savez que vous avez mis en oeuvre et ça
je pense que c'est un très beau travail
pour la france alors un immense merci
[Applaudissements]
merci je sais pas j'ai pas prévu de
discours et je suis très ému de des
propos que vous avez tenus les uns et
les autres et singulièrement du vôtre
monsieur le président nous connaissons
depuis depuis longtemps
j'ai toujours le sénat ne m'a jamais
manqué
quand j'étais mis la défense soumise
affaires étrangères cette commission
fait preuve d'un sens à la fois
patriotique mais sans souci les intérêts
de la france qui est tout à fait
exemplaire à la fois sous votre
présidence et est sous la présidence du
président raffarin
j'ai toujours trouvé dans ces échanges
le d'abord eu un très grand sérieux de
la part de l'ensemble des sénatrices et
sénateurs que
vous travaillez
ce qui est tout à fait essentiel dans lé
poste que vous occupez dans cette
commune de cette commission et puis il
ya toujours une grande confiance entre
nous c'est cette confiance là n'a jamais
été rompu d'aucune manière quelle que
soit la l'appartenance politique de
des différents membres parce que
l'intérêt de la france prix mais on a
traversé vous l'avez dit on à répondre à
pas parlé du terrorisme
beaucoup d'épreuves ensemble en fait
jusqu'à l'épreuve actuelle parce qu'il
ya des preuves de crâne et à l'épreuve
eux il ya les preuves du sahel il ya les
preuves de l'iran qui risque de nous
arriver donc on est dans cette situation
là et puis en même temps avec une
volonté de faire rayonner nos valeurs
par tout ce qui suppose un corps
diplomatique performant je crois que on
y à travailler ensemble pour ce il le
protège et j'ai la chance d'avoir une
très bonne équipe autour de moi vous
savez vous l'avez dit
comme le principe c'est qu'on change pas
une équipe qui gagne un chez l'entente
de l'avoir avec moi elle est soudée mais
très je crois très à la fois disponible
et puis efficace et puis
je crois que si j'ai accordé beaucoup
d'importance à au parlement c'est vrai
c'est vrai du sénat mme c'est vrai aussi
de l'assemblée nationale c'est surtout
parce que j'étais parlementaire 25 ans
donc je vais essayer de répondre à mes
propres préoccupant je suis une ancienne
mais je j'ai essayé de répondre à mes
propres occupations de députés en misant
à ce moment là je respectais pas ce que
parce que maintenant tu es ministre tu
fais comme tu vois là j'ai essayé de le
faire mais j'ai toujours y est toujours
trouvé de votre part eu une une
bienveillance qui que je retrouve ce
soir qui me fait chaud au coeur fera
parce qu'ils étaient comme ça donc je
vais organiser impôts
mercredi prochain
avec vos collègues je n'arrive pas à
faire séparément parce qu'il y en a eu
tellement épouvantable en ce moment
qu'on n'y arrive pas après le 50-1 au
quai d'orsay à 19 heures
avec vos collègues de l'assemblée
nationale et si ça ne vous ennuie pas
les députés et sénateurs bretons parce
que je peux rien faire sans sa
[Rires]
moitié que que nous répondrons à cette
invitation j'ajoute du reste dans le
bilan un peu important il serait parti
mais je veux qu'on garde maintenant il
est là et c'est cacher je veux citer
aussi la loi-cadre aide au développement
franchement là on a eu non pas une
coréalisation du texte juste mesure mais
un peu ça cahier des charges que vous
aviez proposé avec la regrettée
madame de sarnez et là c'est vraiment un
exemple d'un travail est extraordinaire
car je crois vous avez laissé au sénat
qui n'est pas toujours le dernier à
donner son avis constitutionnellement
mais vous nous avez donné la possibilité
d'améliorer ce texte et de lui apporter
un peu plus de cohérence et ça c'est
vraiment grâce à vous personnellement
qu'on le doit je vous ne voulez pas vous
laisser partir sans citer cet exemple
qui m'avait échappé à l'instant alors
bon vent et puis on va bien voir la
mercredi au mercredi de toute façon pour
fêter ensemble en tous les cas un
quinquennat qui ôte idées vos
compétences a été quand même un moment
très fort dès est pour vous et pour nous
le sénat vous est toujours ouvert vous
le savez
merci